We were on really bad terms around April last year
.
Real physical strength speaks for itself, but the reason why everyone's movements were so wonderful
was because they were training there
.  First of all, become a team.It
seems that the answer to Jess's question of what to do from there was a game.It's a
party play.
I asked him if he could forget about the real fence, and he seemed to be
somewhat similar to me, so he was the farthest from us in the real world.
I got addicted to it and had
fights, but by going through so many deaths, we
all became good friends
That might be a wonderful thing
[music]
Aiming to win the next SA
I want to think about the ex-gauge child It's
going to fall right
off, isn't it?
It was a team of only one, and that's
right.